salaires bas niveau général en baisse
l'éducation nationale peine à recruter
de nouveaux profs d'année en année de
moins en moins d'étudiants se présente
au concours du capes dans l'objectif de
devenir prof un problème qui s'est
intensifiée en 2022 alors faut-il
craindre une pénurie prof à la rentrée
réponse dans facture
pour l'explication elle est assez simple
même s'il peut y avoir plusieurs
facteurs c'est le manque d'attractivité
du métier donc ce qui fait qu'il y a de
moins en moins de personnes des
étudiants qui cherchent à passer le
concours on le voit ça peut être
variable suivant les disciplines il ya
des disciplines qui sont
structurellement en crise depuis assez
longtemps comme les mathématiques les
plastiques ou l'allemand mais c'est
quand même un phénomène qui s'intensifie
et qui s'intensifie partout prenons
l'exemple des prof de mathématiques
cette année seulement 816 candidats ont
été admissibles au capes pour 1000 35
postes et c'est la même chose dans
d'autres matières il y a - d'admissibles
que de postes à pourvoir ce qui pose un
véritable problème et cela se ressent
depuis des années déjà en 2010 une
réforme avait été mise en place les
fallait obligatoirement détenir un
master 1 pour pouvoir concourir et en
2022 les choses ont encore changé c'est
vrai que cette année est une année très
particulière puisque à partir de cette
année depuis cette année les candidats
peuvent facile concours à partir du m2
et non plus à partir du m1 donc à partir
du master 2 et pas du master 1 donc en
fait il faut comprendre c'est assez
assez mécanique assez mathématiques les
candidats qui était l'an dernier en aime
un long passé ce concours et ceux qui
l'ont hué va automatiquement ils ne vont
pas repasser en m2 de cette année donc
forcément ça fait
je cite là le directeur général des
ressources humaines du ministère une
baisse mécanique du vivier des candidats
mais évidemment ce n'est pas le seul
problème est d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pap ndiaye il a
rappelé lui même très récemment il a
redit que la crise de recrutement des
professeurs étaient vraiment un problème
structurel qui était aggravée cette
année par le passage du m1 m2 aller
jusqu'au bac + 5 pour finalement être
mal payé à l'arrivée dissuade un certain
nombre d'aspirants professeurs en effet
cette faible rémunération renforce
considérablement le manque
d'attractivité du métier les enseignants
français ont perdu entre 15 et 25 % de
rémunération en cours des 20 dernières
années peut-on lire dans un rapport
sénatorial sur la part du budget 2022
consacré à l'éducation nationale l'une
des premières pistes pour faire face à
ce manque d'attractivité serait donc
d'augmenter le salaire des professeurs
nous installons ne parle même plus de
revalorisation on parle de rattrapage
salarial il suffit de regarder toutes
les enquêtes tous les chiffres sont à
disposition le pouvoir d'achat des
enseignants ne cesse de diminuer et
depuis longtemps c'est pas liée
spécifiquement au gouvernement ou au
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron c'était
déjà le cas avant et ce sera
probablement encore le cas après s'il
n'y a pas de rattrapage salarial
important
la rémunération des profs a fortement
baissé ces dernières années en 1981 un
professeur débutant gagné 2,3 fois le
smic en 2021 ce même professeur débutant
ne gagnait plus qu'une virgule deux fois
le smic
quand vous êtes par exemple diplômé en
mathématiques aujourd'hui le marché de
l'emploi du secteur privé fait vous
pouvez trouver un poste beaucoup plus
attractif que d'être prof donc
évidemment il faut jouer sur le levier
de la rémunération prenons un exemple
concret avec un bac +5 de mathématiques
il est possible de devenir prof de maths
et gagner en début de carrière à peine
1800 euros par mois avec ce même bac + 5
il est aussi possible de devenir
ingénieur sécurité et gagnez un début de
carrière plus de 2500 euros par mois
selon un rapport de la dares 68 postes
d'enseignants resteront non pourvus
si à 2030 alors que vont faire les 12
millions d'écoliers de collégiens de
lycéens s'ils n'ont pas de professeur à
la rentrée la qualité de l'enseignement
risque d'être à nouveau impacter en 2021
près de 10% des cours ont été entre
guillemets perdu en raison de
professeurs absents non remplacés
d'après un rapport de la cour des
comptes
pour éviter ce problème le gouvernement
mise sur les contractuels nous recrutons
ces enseignants qui sont souvent des
personnes diplômées qui parfois ont eu
une autre carrière avant afin d'assurer
la rentrée dans de bonnes conditions et
de faire que devant chaque classe il y
est bien un ou une professeure dès la
rentrée l'académie de versailles a
récemment mis en place des sessions de
job dating avec d entretien d'une
vingtaine de minutes pour recruter de
nouveaux profs une façon de faire qui
n'est pas nouvelle mais qui continue de
déplaire aux syndicats c'est quand même
la première fois que l'on met en place
de la com pour s'en féliciter comme si
c'était quelque chose de formidable
alors que c'est au contraire la marque
d'un échec et d'une crise il a vidé qui
moi parce que j'avais un char dans ce
trou j'allais dire albatros devenir
vétérinaire ya pas de souci tout va bien
ou alors j'ai déjà pris l'avion pourquoi
je le piloterait pas donc effectivement
c'est anormal et ce recrutement massif
et structurelles aujourd'hui à des
personnels contractuels montre bien la
crise et versailles n'est évidemment pas
la seule académie en france à faire face
à ce problème et à chercher de nouvelles
solutions et je pourrais par exemple
aussi citer l'académie de nancy metz qui
a mis en place un système où en fait il
ya une demi-douzaine de professeurs qui
vont être recrutés et qui vont assurer
l'enseignement à distance pour remplacer
des collègues absents alors évidemment
on peut se poser la question remplacé à
distance est ce que c'est vraiment une
solution et le rectorat de nancy metz
m'a confié qu'évidemment il préférerait
avoir des profs en présentiel devant
tous les m mais il y avait certaines
zones de l'académie qui étaient très
éloignées d'un quelle personne ne
voulait aller enseigner donc l'idée
c'était quand même de pouvoir assurer
une continuité pédagogique même si faire
appel à des contractuels va sans doute
permettre d'éviter au maximum lé
absences de profs à la rentrée cette
solution ne résoudra pas le problème sur
le long terme alors il y aura t'il comme
le gouvernement l'a sur un professeur
devant chaque classe eh bien il faudra
attendre septembre pour le savoir